regardeousousee
voiséphs sont devant bien prendre comme
ça les arbres tomb tomber sur les
éléphants ou pas faut déjà que je trouve
les éléphants les éléphants là là on est
là on est en dessous les éléphants sont
en dessous de nous les arbres morts ok
là s'éloigner un peu sil peut revenir
vers les éléphants maintenant on va les
faire rentrer dans le champ oui il s'en
V il s'en V en courant
merde depuis j'ai par les arbres morts
en contre jour tu vois on voyait
beaucoup beaucoup mieux
ok on va faire comme je voulais faire ok
let's
go
va passer entre les Jaun Sok sur leséphs
derrière ça va faire chier
ça
solutionok
ok dou
douattends qu'il soit remis dans
l'X
ach bien
les
déjà VO pas les
éléph mais trop long comme PL onit pas
les ares tu les voisph je vois
pas
ok va plus lge s'il te plaît et puis
après tu tombes dessus sinon on va
encore les rater faut vraiment que tu
ok vraiment que tu te les prennes avant
de partir tu te
les encore un petit peu d'Ang parceil y
a un quite voilà
ESS de tomber bien rester dans les
arbres de pas être trop dans il y a pas
d'arbre tu
vois
il un peu sur ta gauche
Tang les y en a dedans je vois pas moi
je non non non pas encore n est pas
encore mais après ça un peu il vont être
un peu à gauche on monte un peu à gauche
écoute ce qu'on va faire on va on y
arrive on y arrive dessus attends il pas
encore est encore sur les arbres al les
éléphant il vont arriver ils vont
rentrer les voilà les voilà les OK alors
tu les vois moi je vois pas les
éléphants
si moi VO ils sont juste à là ils sont
au milieu du
cadre zoome un peu dessus avec les
arbres un peu autour là quand même hein
les arbres son Plô devant eux hein
devant eux hein notre gauche
he les arbres morts partout tous les
arbres tombés
voilà c'est pas du tout Buleux he pas du
tout ouais mais on s'enroule donc je
suis bien obligé de le corriger et là tu
es complètement
euh encore tu es encore débûé hein oui
parce qu'on s'enroule voilà là je
j'arrive
là on continue à rouler autour
attendsale
c'est beau en contrejour tu as tous les
arbres par terre étalés moi je vois très
mal dans mon écran mais c'est à l'œil
c'est vachement
beau là c'est beau hein il y a vraiment
le troupeau un déc super ça
c'est be
attention c'est
magnifique les ééphants dans le coin à
droite les arbres devant à
gauche
éléphants
c'estb bien les AR quand
même par
TER
long
ok pass estce qu'on pour on va passer
devant et on s'en va ok ok est-ce qu'on
pour essayer de faire un stationnaire
quand même auudessus en
grand
tu veux monter ou tu veux
rester soit
effrayé on grimpe on grie on GRI quand
on peut rester on grimpe on grime on GRI
ok d là ok en plein d là je rien
plein VE qu'onte maintenant si on peut
rester stationnaire on on est
stationnaire là on est stationnaire
pratiquement on se décale un
peu là on 149 de vitesse
je suis carrément immobile alors moi
parce que tu
veux on est vraiment là on bouge pas
pour moi on bouge pas du tout
là
on peut le tenir encore un
peu les ombres c'est vachement beau là
ils sont pas énervés du
tout faut sortir de ce plan aussi
heinoublie pas tu les as bien là tu as
vraiment des éléphants qui bougent ils
avancent c'est vachement beau
ça alle sortir du champ s Bou voilà ils
vont ils vont traverser le champ c'est
beau c'est beau avec les ombres là
magnifique très beau
les ah merde Mo je me retourne non mais
tu aurais pu laisser sortir du champ tu
en fix non tenait plus là non mais tu
rest fixe là il a pas bougé
ni laiss sortir
eux resserre resserre ils vont ils ils
vont sortir du S resserre est comme ça r
encore un peu ou et tu restes fixe et tu
laisses sortir du champ quoi c'est du
pilote aussi le
hein
vasy je la tiens pas
là trou vertical ouis ah c'est dommage
c'est beau
ça ils sont dans le bon sens
ou quand on aille ou qu'on parte
maintenanton parss attends
attends ils vont sortir avec un peu
chance il s'en vont ce bien eux voilà
regarde ils commence à prendre à prendre
la route ah ça bouge
quoi ça se balade Z peut-être pas trop
trop fort ça se balade
hein là c'est bien là ça tient et il
bouge pas eu
aller là ils sont derrière hein par que
nous on s'en va là ils sont derrière
nous là ah oui là
ONEM est-ce qu'on peut se mettre devant
ah oui non devant eux
derrière eux
justemente qu' soit fix lesés'en aller
soit par on pas
pas tu peux'en aller sur l'air coup de
ok sont derrière nous là que nous on
soit a pour F bientôt les
enfants
qu' se passe quelque chose il bouge
pas va mettre
vertical pasim de cul tu
sais je pass
sor de
Ch comme
tucoup de comme ça on les
accompagne les accomp pas trs bien pasé
ce que tu
fais dans
cé
voilà ils partent vers
l'avant il par pas en fin de compte il
reste groupé c'est B ça leses son
magnifque à eux là allez on on est parti
c'est bon remonte dans le champ parti la
partir on les laisse partir c'est bien
c'est bien il bouge làon remonte t on
s'en va c'est bon ou paste vers
l'horizon on vair
le allonsous comme ça on va s'éloigner
de comme ça tout doucement voilà comme
ça'en éloig très bien très bien c'est
beau
çaen élo c'est bien ok a les arbres tout
Contin comme ça c'est bien les
AR
plein d' d' BR c'est vachement beau par
terre c'est vachement beau ces
arbres
payageici